Good morning. Good morning, Jason. Or afternoon or wherever our listeners are. Wherever we find you, sure. Does anybody have big plans today at all for anything? I mean, I'm doing a pretty smoking podcast in the next couple of minutes. It's called Smartless. Oh.
早上好。早上好，杰森。或者下午好，不管我们的听众在哪里。不管我们在哪里找到你，当然。今天有没有人有什么宏伟的计划？我的意思是，接下来的几分钟我要做一个非常精彩的播客。它叫 Smartless。哦。
Cue the music. Smart. Smart Less Smart Less How's Seattle? Will, how's Seattle?
音乐响起。Smart。Smart Less Smart Less 西雅图怎么样？威尔，西雅图怎么样？
You're up there in Seattle visiting family? I'm doing a little thing tonight with our friend Ed Vedder tonight. We're just doing like a little... Is it Ed now? Yep.
你在西雅图探亲吗？今晚我和我们的朋友埃德·维德（Ed Vedder）有个小活动。我们只是做个小……现在叫埃德了吗？对。
And he's just growing up a little bit. And Eddie and I are doing... a little thing tonight and he's going to perform he claims that I might help him sing a song on stage that's not going to happen
他稍微长大了一点。埃迪和我在今晚有个小活动，他要表演，他声称我可能会在舞台上帮他唱首歌，那是不可能的
because he's heard your impression of him no he hasn't yet and I plan on doing it but he said he was like hey do you want to I'm gonna you know what song do you want to hear
因为他听过你模仿他，不，他还没听过，我打算这么做，但他说，嘿，你想不想，我要，你知道你想听什么歌
I was like well what song do you not want to play and he was like well anything I don't know what you don't know and he goes well you get up here and you'll sing everybody likes to sing right and I'm like no Eddie
我说，好吧，你不想演奏什么歌，他说，任何我不懂你不知道的事，他说，好吧，你到这儿来，你会唱歌的，每个人都喜欢唱歌，对吧，我说，不，埃迪
nobody wants to hear me singing you have to do unless it's hello Leasley I couldn't you know what I couldn't love him more. He's up on that level of those dudes
没有人想听我唱歌，除非是——你好，里斯利，我简直不能，你知道吗，我太爱他了。他是那些家伙中的一员
that I just absolutely adore. I include him. I include our friend William Bradley Pitt in that, whom I just adore. I just have like massive man crush. He's got the middle name down and everything. Do you know a sign? I think it's exit.
我绝对崇拜他们。我把他算在内。我把我们的朋友威廉·布拉德利·皮特（William Bradley Pitt）也算在内，我太崇拜他了。我简直有强烈的崇拜之情。他连中间名都弄清楚了。你知道一个标志吗？我想是出口。
Meaning get out of my face. They don't want me around, but that's okay. Wait, do you remember when he was on and then afterwards he sent us all ukuleles or something? Remember that? Yeah, he did, I know. Yeah, so it's nice. He's such a class act.
意思是滚出我的视线。他们不想让我呆在附近，但没关系。等等，还记得他来的时候，后来给我们寄了尤克里里琴什么的吗？记得吗？是的，他确实寄了，我知道。是的，所以很好。他真是个有品位的人。
He's such a great dude. And anyway, so yeah, that's why I'm up here. I'm doing this thing tonight with him, which is going to be fun. I got my buddy Cutch is coming in from Calgary because he's such a fan. So I said, why don't you come and join, you can hang out? What's a Cutch? Yeah, my buddy, Dave McCutchen. He's one of my oldest friends.
他真是个大好人。总之，是的，这就是我来这里的原因。今晚我和他一起搞这个活动，这会很有趣。我的死党卡奇（Cutch）要从卡尔加里赶来，因为他是超级粉丝。所以我说，你为什么不来加入，你可以一起玩？什么是卡奇？是的，我的死党，戴夫·麦卡琴（Dave McCutchen）。他是我最老的朋友之一。
And his name is Cutch. Oh, hey, Cutch. Yeah, how's it going? Well, is he a dirty flames fan? No, he's from Calgary, but originally from Cunora, Ontario, eh? Oh, so that. makes him a dirty leaf fan. Yeah.
他的名字叫卡奇。哦，嘿，卡奇。是的，最近怎么样？嗯，他是个讨厌的火焰队球迷吗？不，他来自卡尔加里，但最初来自安大略省的肯ora，是吗？哦，这让他成了讨厌的枫叶队球迷。是的。
Actually, we got room for the Leafs. We got room for the Leafs. It's a really catchy nickname. You know what, Sean? Wait until the guest gets in here. Save some of that. Anyway. Anyway.
其实，我们给枫叶队留了位置。我们给枫叶队留了位置。这是一个非常引人注目的绰号。你知道吗，肖恩？等嘉宾进来再说。留着点。总之。总之。
J.B., what am we going to see you? Are we going to see you on the East Coast? Are you going to come to London to see Sean's play? That's the big question. Of course I am. Yeah, isn't that nice? Oh, I didn't know that. Are they coming to stay with you guys?
J.B.，我们什么时候能见到你？我们会在东海岸见到你吗？你会去伦敦看肖恩的戏剧吗？这是个大问题。我当然会去。是吗，太好了？哦，我不知道。他们要和你们住在一起吗？
We're staying with you for like three or four days, aren't we, Shawnee? Yeah, yeah, it's going to be great. It's going to be super fun. It's going to be super fun. So, yeah, you know, go ahead, Willie. You know, you go. No, just, I was, Jason reminded me of staying with me in the house. I was talking to a friend that said, we were talking about, like, grocery shopping and once again.
我们要和你们住三四天，对吧，肖尼？是的，是的，会很棒的。会超级有趣的。会超级有趣的。所以，是的，你知道，说吧，威利。你说吧。不，只是，我，杰森提醒我和我住在一起。我和一个朋友聊天，我们谈到了杂货购物之类的话题，又来了。
And he's like, I go, where can I get some good milk? And he's like, cow? And I was like, yeah, cow's milk. Do we talk about this? And I was like, it just sounded gross when he said it because I forgot that, you know, that's where, like, that milk comes out of a teat. Like, I know now he's. meant like almond milk oat milk i was like because i didn't think there's any other milk anyway let's just back let's go to the very very beginning of this of the great story i i want where when's the
他说，我说，我在哪里能买到好牛奶？他说，牛？我说，对，牛奶。我们谈过这个吗？我说，当他说出来的时候听起来很恶心，因为我忘了，你知道，那牛奶是从乳头里挤出来的。就像，我现在知道他指的是杏仁奶燕麦奶，我说，因为我以为没有别的牛奶了，不管怎样，让我们回到这个伟大故事的最开始，我想要，什么时候
like way will i'll just ask you will when's the last time you approach somebody and ask them where you could get some good milk right that was the question yeah not milk just general but this is somebody you know not a stranger right this is correct okay because because because what's the context of like were you guys mid-conversation or is it no i was like you were i was talking about Because I'm like, where do we go, grocery shopping? Where's the new latest? In London? In London, because I don't know if they have, like, American stuff.
就像，威尔，我只想问你，威尔，你上次接近某人并问他们你在哪里可以买到好牛奶是什么时候？这就是问题所在，是的，不是牛奶，泛指，但这是你认识的人，不是陌生人，对吧？这是对的，好吧，因为，因为上下文是什么，你们是在谈话中，还是没有，我当时就像，你在，我在谈论，因为我像，我们去哪里，买杂货？最新的是在哪里？在伦敦？在伦敦，因为我不知道他们是否有美国的东西。
Like, what's the equivalent? And you hear, good milk's hard to find. Well, I didn't know, yes. I want really good non-fat milk. Anyway, let's get to the gas. You really, no, we're not getting there. We're going to stay here for a minute until we knock it out of you. Sean, you asked somebody where in London you could get good milk?
就像，等价物是什么？你听说，好牛奶很难找。好吧，我不知道，是的。我想要非常好的脱脂牛奶。不管怎样，我们去找嘉宾吧。你真的，不，我们不去那儿。我们要在这里呆一会儿，直到从你嘴里问出来。肖恩，你问过伦敦哪里能买到好牛奶吗？
I've heard it's a real challenge to find some good non-fat cow milk. Honestly, and I love you, and I know a lot of people. But honestly, what the fuck are you talking about? I drink it every day, because I don't really drink soda anymore. Well, I tell you what, it's a good segue, because our guest might be able to help you locate some good milk in England. When it comes to find in good teats. Yeah, she, well, she lives here.
我听说找点好的脱脂牛奶真是个挑战。老实说，我爱你们，我也认识很多人。但老实说，你在胡说八道什么？我每天都喝，因为我不再怎么喝苏打水了。好吧，我告诉你，这是一个很好的过渡，因为我们的嘉宾可能会帮你找到英国一些好的牛奶。说到寻找好的乳头。是的，她，好吧，她住在这里。
Yeah, take that back. You don't want to take it back. Also, because she's a really classy guest, you're really going to want to take it back. Damn it, Sean, you put me up to that. It's a phenomenal guest that we have today and she hails from London She lives in London She's an Academy Award winner
收回这话。你不想收回。另外，因为她是一个非常有品位的嘉宾，你真的会想收回的。该死，肖恩，你怂恿我这么做的。我们今天迎了一位杰出的嘉宾，她来自伦敦，她住在伦敦，她是一位奥斯卡奖得主
Three nominations, three-time Golden Globe Winner, seven nominations Taking home two Emmys out of five nominations You might remember her from her turn in confetti Or is the hairdresser in I Could Never Be Your Woman He's trying to throw a song Or even as Ian's mother in 2005's one day I remember her from one of my all-time favorite TV shows
三项提名，三届金球奖得主，七项提名 获得两座艾美奖（共五次提名） 你可能还记得她在《彩纸》中的表演 或者在《我绝不会成为你的女人》中饰演理发师 他正试图插播一首歌 甚至在2005年的《一天》中饰演伊恩的母亲 我记得她是我有史以来最喜欢的电视节目之一
Broadchurch films like The Father for which she was nominated for Academy Award, and of course the favorite for which she won an Academy Award, which is a new film called The Roses, Whichie Co-stars, Benedict Cumberbatch, comes out of 29th, give it up for a huge welcome. Olivia Coleman. Hi!
《小镇疑云》以及像《父亲》这样的电影（她因此获得奥斯卡提名），当然还有《宠儿》（她因此获得奥斯卡奖），这是一部名为《玫瑰家族》的新片，她与本尼迪克特·伯蒂奇（Benedict Cumberbatch）共同主演，将于29日上映，大家热烈欢迎。奥利维娅·科尔曼（Olivia Colman）。嗨！
This is a real pleasure. This is a real pleasure. Hi, guys. Hello, good morning. Hello, Lydia Coleman. Oh, it's so nice to be here. Look how bright and cheery you are. I know.
这真是个荣幸。这真是个荣幸。嗨，伙计们。哈喽，早上好。哈喽，莉迪亚·科尔曼（Lydia Coleman）。哦，来到这里太高兴了。看你们多明亮快乐。我知道。
It's very sunny here. Really classing up Will's list. Will's list was really starting to sink a little bit. Was it? Yeah. You really buoyed it. I needed to turn around. And thanks for the teets comment.
这里阳光明媚。真的给威尔的名单增添了品位。威尔的名单刚才真的有点往下沉了。是吗？是的。你真的把它撑起来了。我需要扭转局面。谢谢你的乳头发言。
Yeah. Sure. No. I retract that with all apologies. But do you know where to find good non-fat milk there? I know some excellent teets in London. Really? Oh, well.
是的。当然。不。我收回这话，并致以万分歉意。但是你知道在那里哪里能找到好的脱脂牛奶吗？我知道伦敦有一些极好的乳头。真的吗？哦，好吧。
Yeah. Don't you worry. Good, good. Are you in London right now? No, I'm out in the countryside. inside in the sticks. Oh, great. Oh, great.
是的。别担心。好，好。你现在在伦敦吗？不，我在乡下，在穷乡僻壤。哦，太好了。哦，太好了。
Yeah, lovely. But you do live in England full time. I do, yes. Lucky. Yeah. Do you like it? I love it. I love it.
对，太棒了。不过你确实全职住在英国。我是的，没错。真幸运。对。你喜欢吗？我非常喜欢。我太喜欢了。
My mother's British, so I've always sort of had an affinity for it, but I've never spent the amount of time you'd think I would being a son of. But every time I go there. Shrewsbury. Oh, nice. Very nice. Lovely. J.B., do you ever consider getting your UK passport?
我母亲是英国人，所以我对它一直有一种特殊的感情，但我花在那里的时间从来没有你想象的作为一个……的儿子应该花的那么多。不过每次我去那里。什鲁斯伯里。哦，不错。非常不错。太棒了。J.B.，你有没有考虑过拿你的英国护照？
I haven't. Should I? Why, what have you heard about America? Is something... No, all good things, all good things. No, okay, go out the window. Don't turn out the window. I don't get much here in the hostage cell.
我还没拿。我应该拿吗？怎么，你对美国有什么耳闻？是不是有什么……不，都是好事，都是好事。不，好吧，抛到脑后吧。别看窗外。我在人质牢房里可得不到多少消息。
Yes, we're all big fans. We all love England. We spend time there. Sean's on his way there in a couple days. Yeah, I heard. For a while. I'm going to come and see you. You should.
是的，我们都是大粉丝。我们都爱英国。我们在那儿待过。肖恩过几天就要去那儿了。对，我听说了。待一段时间。我要去见你。你真应该去。
I love it. This guy can play piano. Watch out. Get ready to be impressed. So Olivia Coleman, you know, it's funny, I was, I went through your, your, your, your awards that you've won in nominations. You've got like, you've been nominated for like, I think it was like 156 international acting awards and you've won like 65. Did you know, did you not know this? I didn't know that.
我太喜欢了。这家伙会弹钢琴。小心点。准备好被惊艳吧。所以奥利维娅·科尔曼，你知道的，很有趣，我查看了你曾经获得过的奖项和提名。你大概……你获得了大约156项国际表演奖项的提名，你赢得了大约65项。你知道吗，你不知道这个吗？我不知道。
Congratulations, you won. Thanks. But, but what's staggering is, is the breadth of your work, which is, and by that, I mean, not just the actual amount, but the actual, you know, that you've done comedy, you've done drama, and everything in between. And it's really remarkable how you're able to sort of go back and forth between the two.
恭喜你，你获奖了。谢谢。但是，令人震惊的是你的作品的广度，我的意思是，不仅仅是数量上的，而是实际上，你知道的，你演过喜剧，演过剧情片，以及介于两者之间的所有类型。你能够在两者之间自如切换，这真的很了不起。
So my first question to you is, do you, at your heart, consider yourself to be a comedic actor? Do you consider yourself to be a dramatic actor or none of the above? A little bit of all of it? Sure. Yeah, I don't know.
所以我的第一个问题是，从你的内心深处，你认为自己是一个喜剧演员吗？你认为自己是一个剧情片演员，还是以上都不是？两者都有一点？当然。是的，我不知道。
I mean, it's funny talking to all of you guys about it because you all know, you all know. My first work was in comedy, and I loved it. And sometimes you just need someone to take a punt to give you a chance to do the other thing. So comedy has my heart, because that's where I, you know, got work. But I always wanted to do something dramatic,
我的意思是，和你们所有人谈论这个很有趣，因为你们都知道，你们都懂。我的第一份工作是喜剧，我非常喜欢它。有时你只需要有人冒个险给你一个机会去尝试别的东西。所以喜剧占据了我的心，因为那是我的起点，你知道的，我得到了工作。但我一直想做一些偏剧情的东西，
and I was so pleased with someone. What was that punt? What was that punt you're talking about? What was the first? It was Paddy Considine gave me a chance to do a film called Taranosaur. It started as a short film and then he
我非常高兴有人。那是什么冒险？你说的那个冒险是什么？第一个是什么？是帕迪·康斯戴恩给了我一个机会去拍一部叫《暴龙》的电影。它最初是一部短片，然后他
decided he wanted to know what happened to these characters and made it a longer film. What was that? What was that? I want to say 20 years ago? Longer. Yeah, I think we filmed it in 2011.
决定他想知道这些角色的命运如何，于是把它拍成了一部长片。那是什……那是什……我想说是20年前吗？更久。对，我想我们是在2011年拍的。
Okay. 2011, and it was a huge and it was like a big Sundance hit, wasn't it? It was a huge... I mean, it was like it made a lot of waves. It was a... Well, it sort of, at the time,
好的。2011年，这是一部轰动一时的作品，就像是圣丹斯的巨大热门，对吧？它是一个巨大的……我的意思是，它引起了很大的轰动。它是一部……嗯，它在当时，
yeah, Sundance loved it, which makes me love Sundance very much and then and then it was sort of built as the years went by so now film lovers have seen it but at the time it was quite a slow burn I think
是的，圣丹斯很喜欢它，这让我非常喜欢圣丹斯，然后随着时间的推移，它逐渐建立起声誉，所以现在电影爱好者都看过它，但在当时它是一部挺慢热的作品，我认为
but you didn't just get incredible 20 years ago I you know like I imagine that there's been a real you're just you're such a special magic actor. I mean, that is why you can do comedy and drama so well is because it doesn't
但你不仅在20年前获得了难以置信的……我（知道），我想说的是，你一直都是一个非常特别有魔力的演员。我的意思是，这就是为什么你能把喜剧和剧情都演得那么好的原因，因为这不
it doesn't ever seem like you're asking for a laugh. You're never doing a comedy. You're playing a character that is eccentric or whatever, such that it makes us all sort of giggle and the same for drama. So when This is nice. I'm loving
这看起来绝对不像是你在讨要笑声。你从来不是在恶搞喜剧。你饰演的是一个古怪之类的人物，以至于让我们所有人都咯咯直笑，剧情片也是如此。所以当这很好。我很喜欢
this. Well, you won't like this question. I'm very shallow, isn't it? You know, like when did you realize that you were special? And I know that that takes admitting that you think that you don't suck, but you're allowed to admit that you don't suck. And when did it start? Was it, was it, was it acting school? Did somebody tell you you're great? Or did you see yourself do something and go, oh, that, that works for me?
这个。好吧，你不会喜欢这个问题的。我真的很肤浅，对吧？你知道的，比如你什么时候意识到自己很特别的？我知道这需要承认你觉得自己并不烂，但你被允许承认自己并不烂。这一切是什么时候开始的？是，是，是在表演学校吗？有人告诉你你很棒吗？还是你看到自己的表演然后觉得，哦，这，这对我管用？
Yeah. Yeah, I don't know. I mean, do you all remember the moment when you went, okay, don't suck? Right. No, I guess I don't. You do. Wait, Sean, you had a moment where you thought you didn't suck. Many of them. I'm like, oh, my God. No, my first one was... My first one was really, just really quick, and then maybe it'll...
对。对，我不知道。我的意思是，你们都还记得自己当时觉得“好吧，我不烂”的那个时刻吗？对吧？不，我想我不记得。你记得。等等，肖恩，你曾经有过一个觉得自己不烂的时刻。有很多次。我当时想，哦，天哪。不，我的第一次是……我的第一次非常、非常快，然后也许它会……
Great to have you on the show, Sean. Thank you, so much. No, I remember, like, you know, the pilot of this show I did Will and Grace for many years. We love this show. It's so complicated. It's actually not the opposite of it's complicated.
很高兴你能来参加节目，肖恩。非常感谢。不，我记得，就像，你知道的，这个节目的试播集，我演了多年《威尔和格蕾丝》。我们很喜欢这个节目。太复杂了。实际上正好相反，一点也不复杂。
He's gay, she's gay, very gay. Wait, wait, it was the pilot, Shawnee? It was the pilot that I didn't really, I'd never done a TV show. So it was like a pilot and I walked in not knowing how cameras were anything, right? And I walked in and I got a laugh on just like some benign line like, hey Will, can I borrow your blank? I don't know what it was. And people laughed. I'm like, in my head, I'm like, why are they laughing?
他是同性恋，她是同性恋，非常同性恋。等等，等等，那是试播集吗，肖尼？那是试播集，我其实不太懂，我从来没演过电视剧。所以就像是一部试播集，我走进去时根本不懂摄像机是怎么运作的，对吧？我走进去，然后就一句无足轻重台词逗大家笑了，比如“嘿，威尔，我能借一下你的某某吗”。我不知道具体是什么。然后大家笑了。我当时脑子里想的是，他们在笑什么？
I just said something. And then at the end of the pilot that night, the first assistant director came up to me and she was like, you know, she was like, you're great, you're amazing. I'm like, really? Like, I didn't understand any of it. Yeah.
我只是随口说了句话。然后在试播集拍摄当晚结束时，第一副导演走到我面前，她就说，你知道的，她就说，你太棒了，你太惊艳了。我当时想，真的吗？就像，我完全搞不懂这一切。对。
It does take hearing it from the outside, doesn't it? I mean, Olivia, was there a moment there where somebody, I mean, sometimes it's a parent, you know, that goes, hey, you know, you've done good or a teacher or was it, do you remember, was there a moment like that? Yeah, maybe my first ever school play. when I was 16 and that's the first time I'd done any acting and yeah I've got to say I really enjoyed
这确实需要从外界听到评价，对吧？我的意思是，奥利维娅，当时有没有那么一个时刻，有人——我的意思是，有时是父母，你知道的，他们会说，嘿，你知道的，你干得不错，或者是一个老师，或者，你记得吗，有过这样的时刻吗？对，也许是我生平第一场学校话剧。当时我16岁，那是第一次演戏，是的，我得说我真的很享受
afterwards people clapping that was brilliant at that age too that's such a tricky age you're just coming on to... Oh so shit it's everything so rubbish and finally thought oh and my mum and dad who just couldn't really speak afterwards went oh fuck yeah that's a good thing Yeah, yeah. That's interesting. I know it's very English to not want to, you know, sort of pat yourself on the back.
事后大家的掌声，那太棒了。在那个年纪也是，那是如此棘手的年纪，你正处于……哦，简直太烂了，一切都太垃圾了，最后终于觉得“哦”，我的爸爸妈妈在事后简直说不出话来，然后说“哦，操，对，这挺不错的”。是的，是的。这很有趣。我知道不想自我表扬是非常英国人的做法。
And I get it. But there are those moments that you have. There's undeniable where you go like, yeah, okay, I was kind of... J.B., I remember when we were doing Arrested Development 20 years ago, over 20 years ago. And remember that? There was a guy one of the first editors. And I remember you and I were walking, and he came down the stairs. You and I were on the old culver lot.
我懂。但确实有那些时刻。那是不可否认的，你会觉得，好吧，我当时确实……J.B.，我记得20年前我们拍《发展受阻》的时候，那是20多年前了。还记得吗？有个家伙，是最初的剪辑师之一。我记得你和我正在散步，他从楼梯上走下来。你和我在旧卡尔弗片场。
And he said, do you remember that guy? And he came over and he goes, guys, I've been cutting the show. And we'd only made like three episodes. And he was like, guys, this show is really funny. We're like, really? I know, you never know. We had no idea because we were in a vacuum.
他说，还记得那个家伙吗？他走过来对我们说，伙计们，我一直在剪这部剧。当时我们才拍了三集左右。他就像是，伙计们，这部剧真的很好笑。我们当时想，真的吗？我知道，你永远猜不到。我们当时完全不知道，因为我们身处真空之中。
And he's like, really good. I remember doing 12th night, the Shakespeare played 12th night in high school. Olivia, we're going to beat you in one second. Yeah. No, I want to know about your high school the play that you said you had a response to. And I didn't know what,
他说，真的很好。我记得在高中时演过《第十二夜》，那部莎士比亚戏剧《第十二夜》。奥利维娅，我们马上就要超过你了。对。不，我想了解一下你高中时演的那部剧，你刚才说你得到了回应。而我不知道，
I didn't understand what I was saying. It's literally Shakespeare. And I got a laugh on some, I'm like, why are they laughing? And I was 16 years old. Same thing. But what was yours? Oh, the prime of Miss Jean Brody.
我根本不懂自己在说什么。这可是字面意义上的莎士比亚。我凭某句台词博得了笑声，当时我想，他们为什么在笑？我那时16岁。情况一样。但你的剧是什么？哦，简·布罗迪小姐的盛年。
Which I obviously didn't have a clue what it meant at the time. Yeah, yeah. And looking back now, it was all sort of about fascism and... So at that age, that's the age where you start to think about college, right, and picking a career. And so it was kind of timely that you kind of got this pat on the back. And did you then, at that moment, choose this is the direction I'm going to go? Well, I sort of, I never really admitted it to anyone out loud, but in my head I thought, I wonder if I'm allowed to be an actor.
我当时显然完全不知道那是什么意思。对，对。现在回想起来，那一切都跟法西斯主义有关……所以到那个年纪，正是开始考虑上大学、选择职业的时候。所以你能得到这样的肯定，也算挺合时宜的。那你当时，就在那一刻，选择了这就是我要走的方向吗？嗯，我其实，从来没大声跟任何人承认过，但在心里我想，不知道我能不能当个演员。
Because I didn't come from that, you know, so I didn't know. Allowed. Yeah. And so I didn't tell, I went off to teacher training college, which I left after a term and then worked as a cleaner for a long time and still sort of secretly thinking, I really want to try the acting thing. Yeah.
因为我不是吃这行饭出身的，你知道，所以我根本不知道。允许。是的。所以我没说，我去了师范学院，读了一个学期就退学了，然后当了很长时间的清洁工，心里却还在暗暗想着，我真的很想尝试演戏这事。对。
What did you teach in the train? But you went to Bristol, sorry, you went to Old Vic The other? school though, yeah? Brislavik afterwards, yes. So, yes, I went to the teacher training college where I met my husband who was at the university and we were 20, we were doing a play then. And I walked into the rehearsal room and saw him
你在培训班里教什么？不过你去的是布里斯托，抱歉，你去的是老维克戏剧学院对吧？布里斯托老维克之后，是的。所以，是的，我去了师范学院，在那里我遇到了我丈夫，他当时在读大学，我们20岁的时候，当时我们在排练一部话剧。我走进排练室，看到了他
and got Thunderbolts. And then we did a play together. And he was doing law but was sort of didn't really like it. And then I said, run away with me and we'll go and be artists. and join the circus, and so he did. It was nice. He finished his degree because he's, you know, proper, clever. And then what was that first job or moment
然后被丘比特之箭射中了。接着我们一起排了一部剧。他当时在学法律，但其实并不是很喜欢。然后我说，跟我私奔吧，我们去当艺术家，加入马戏团，然后他就去了。挺好的。他完成了学位，因为他嘛，很聪明，很正经。然后，那是怎样的一份工作或时刻
where you go, okay, this is something I think I'm going to be able to make a living at this? Well, we went to drama school. He got in first, and then I got in the year after, and we did drama school together, and then I got a job just before my last term, which was a sketch show. and I don't think it was particularly great
让你觉得，好吧，这大概是我能靠它谋生的行业了？嗯，我们去了戏剧学校。他先进去了，然后我第二年进去的，我们一起上了戏剧学校，然后在我最后一个学期开始前我得到了一份工作，那是一个小品秀。而且我觉得它其实并不算特别好
I wasn't very particularly good in it but the fact that I'd got a job I was so excited and then I felt like I'd know I'd earned some money and I could actually put actor on my passport yeah that's cool yeah it was exciting and then not long after that when did peep show come into into your world peep show yeah not long after that
我在里面表现得也不是特别好，但事实是我找到了一份工作，我太兴奋了，然后我觉得我知道我赚到钱了，我终于可以在护照上填上演员了，对，这太酷了，对，太令人兴奋了，然后没过多久，《窥视秀》是什么时候进入你的世界的？《窥视秀》？对，没过多久
great yeah oh thanks yeah so good so good oh I love it when people People love Peep Show. Oh, yeah, that show. It's so good. That was, Rob and David, who I'd met when I had left my teacher training college, Rob Webb, David Mitchell. Yeah. They had, you know, spent the interim time writing and working hard.
太棒了，噢谢谢，太棒了，太棒了，噢，我喜欢别人喜欢《窥视秀》。噢，对，那部剧。太棒了。那是罗勃和大卫，我离开师范学院时认识的，罗勃·韦伯，大卫·米切尔。对。他们你知道的，把中间的时间都用来写作和努力工作了。
And then they met Sam and Jesse who wrote Peep Show, Sam Bain, Jesse Armstrong. And they said, we need a woman. And they went, oh, our mate, Collie, we could try him. her and it was great and I was called into the BBC for an audition I was so excited and I couldn't work out why
然后他们遇到了萨姆和杰西，也就是《窥视秀》的编剧，萨姆·贝恩，杰西·阿姆斯壮。他们说，我们需要一个女性角色。然后他们就想，哦，我们的朋友科莉，我们可以试试她。这太棒了，我被叫去BBC试镜，我太兴奋了，我当时搞不懂为什么
and it was then and they'd also yeah so nervous and they'd also got me in for the sketch show which was did you did that it must have helped sort of shape your sort of your comedic point of view a little bit
然后就是那个时候，他们也，对，太紧张了，他们还让我去试镜那个小品秀，那是你做过吗？那一定有助于塑造你的一些喜剧视角吧
working on that show with those guys yeah and I mean I could I couldn't write for shit. If Ogun was to my head, I couldn't write anything funny, but they can. And so they sort of make it easy. We say their words and, you know, you appear to be funny, which was nice. I would imagine working in that environment with those guys, you know, and you with your talent and working for the, I know it's not to embarrass you.
和那些家伙一起做那个节目，是的，我的意思是，我根本写不出什么好东西。如果拿枪指着我的头，我也写不出任何搞笑的东西，但他们可以。所以他们把一切变得很简单。我们念着他们的台词，然后，你知道的，你看起来就很好笑，这挺好的。我能想象在那种环境下和那些家伙一起工作，你知道的，以你的天赋，为……我知道这不是为了让你难堪。
We're just, these are just facts, Olivia, so you have to accept them. Okay? Yeah, yeah, yeah. We have to, but taking that, and I think working in that way with those guys who are so funny, and you're so funny, and as you guys developed that show
我们只是，这些都只是事实，奥利维亚，所以你必须接受它们。好吗？对，对，对。我们必须接受，但是把这个拿来，我觉得以那种方式和那些非常搞笑的家伙一起工作，而且你也很搞笑，随着你们一起发展那个节目
and worked on Peep Show over the years, I wonder if that sort of that spontaneity and that ability to work in comedy helped you later on as you sort of gravitated towards more dramatic roles. Yeah, maybe. I think, and, you know, I don't know how you feel about it, you have to sort of be
并且多年来一直致力于《窥视秀》，我想那种即兴创作的能力和在喜剧中工作的能力，是否对你后来转向更多戏剧性角色有所帮助。对，也许吧。我觉得，而且，你知道，我不知道你是怎么看的，你必须具备
have an enormous dollop of humility I think to be able to for people to laugh at you and with you yeah you got to really pull your pants down yeah yeah okay I'll do it some people aren't comfortable
一种极其巨大的谦逊，我认为，才能让人们嘲笑你，并与你一起欢笑。是的，你真的得把裤子脱下来。是的，好吧，我来做。有些人会觉得不自在
I think some people aren't comfortable with it and I think that helps with you've got to show vulnerability in the drama side and maybe because it's quite brave to show yourself to be an idiot in front of people and for them to laugh and to be broken. Yeah, it is. And to be broken, but also because, as you know, so much,
我觉得有些人对此感到不自在，而我认为这有助于在戏剧方面展现出脆弱感，也许因为在众人面前展现自己是个白痴，让他们笑话，甚至被击碎，是需要相当大的勇气的。是的，确实如此。而且要被击碎，但同时也是因为，正如你所知，很大程度上，
you know, timing plays a big part of it in comedy, right? And so when you, and you really have to, in comedy, for the most, you really have to listen. I mean, if ever there was a discipline, you know, an area in our world that you have to listen is comedy, because you have to, it's so important to be able to land stuff. And so that, if you bring that into dramatic work, you know, you are really listening
你知道，时机在喜剧中占据了很大一部分，对吧？所以当你，而且在喜剧中，大多数情况下你真的必须要倾听。我的意思是，如果说我们的世界里有哪个领域、哪个纪律要求你必须倾听，那就是喜剧，因为你必须这样做，能够让包袱响起来是如此重要。所以，如果你把这一点带到戏剧创作中，你知道，你真的在倾听
and you really understand rhythm. There is a sort of almost a musicality to it, you know? Yeah, totally. You're explaining it really well, yeah. Done. Yeah. First time. Thanks well.
而且你真的理解节奏。这里面几乎有一种音乐性，你知道吗？完全同意。你解释得太棒了，是的。说得好。第一次。谢谢。
First time I've done it right. I'm always surprised that people are still shocked when people in comedy can do drama. It's like, oh my God, what? I know. It's like, well, where does it come from? It doesn't work the other way, though, doesn't. Yeah.
我第一次做对了。每当人们对喜剧演员能演正剧感到惊讶时，我总是很吃惊。就好像，噢我的天哪，什么？我知道。就好像，好吧，这从何而来？但反过来却行不通，对吧。对。
No, it doesn't. Yeah. Well, often it doesn't, yeah. Yeah, I mean, obviously, plenty can. But it is odd to how it's easier to make them move from comedy to drama than the other way around. I think that it does have something to do with that, with that rhythm and that listening and all that stuff and being present. Like, you're forced to. Oh, look, somebody's just delivered a drink.
不，行不通。对。好吧，通常行不通，对。是的，我的意思是，当然，很多人可以。但奇怪的是，从喜剧转到正剧似乎比反过来要容易。我想这确实与那种节奏、倾听以及所有这些保持当下状态的东西有关。就像，你被迫这样做。噢，看，有人刚送来一杯饮料。
So my husband's just brought me a massive gin and tonic. There we go. Oh, that's great. It's that time of the evening. It is massive. I just want to... Hi. Sorry.
所以我丈夫刚刚给我拿了一大杯金汤力。这就对了。哦，太棒了。傍晚正是时候。真的很大一杯。我只想……嗨。抱歉。
That's Ed. That's Ed, the bartender? What's Ed? Thanks, Ed. Thanks, Ed. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Didn't I just see a trailer for...
那是埃德。那是埃德，调酒师？哪个埃德？谢谢你，埃德。谢谢你，埃德。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。我刚才是不是看到一个预告片……
You've got a hilarious comedy coming out. Oh, excellent segue. Yes. But what is it? It's... I want to say it's like War of the Roses, yes? Yes. Yes.
你有一部超级搞笑的喜剧要上映了。哦，完美的过渡。是的。但那是什么？那是……我想说这有点像《玫瑰战争》，对吧？是的。是的。
Is that what it's called? It was in my introduction, Jason. You see you weren't present and listening. Wait, I wasn't really much. Maybe I was busy clapping because I guessed it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Wait, wait, is it War of the Roses? Yes, so, well, that was a jumping off point.
是叫这个名字吗？它在我的介绍里啊，杰森。你看你刚才根本没专心听。等等，我其实没怎么……也许我刚才一直在忙着鼓掌，因为我猜对了。对，对，对。等等，等等，是叫《玫瑰战争》吗？是的，所以，嗯，那是灵感来源。
Yes. So, yes, you know, Tony McNamara, amazing. Tony McNamara, writer, he has loved War of the Roses, as we all did, and he's slightly changed a bit. And so it's called The Roses. But that was definitely a big influence. Gotcha, gotcha. Wow.
是的。所以，你知道的，托尼·麦克纳马拉，太棒了。托尼·麦克纳马拉，编剧，他一直很喜欢《玫瑰战争》，就像我们所有人一样，他稍微做了一些改所以它叫《玫瑰罗斯夫妇》。但那绝对是一个巨大的影响。明白了，明白了。哇。
Who's the fella? Benedict Cumberbatch. Oh, that's great. That part I remember. Yeah, I remember something hearing about Cumberbatch and your... You know, you probably've heard this all the time. Americans, I think, a lot of us were so and are still enamored with British comedy, right? That's nice.
那男主角是谁？本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇。哦，太棒了。这一部分我记得。是的，我记得好像听过关于康伯巴奇和你的……你知道，你可能经常听到这种说法。美国人，我想，我们当中有很多人过去是、现在依然对英国喜剧着迷，对吧？那挺好的。
Even the most crass, vulgar, like, sketch shows or comedy shows that come out of... There's still, like, a sophistication to the... You know what I mean? There's still, like, a slickness to it and a subtlety. He's getting to, he always gets to. He wants to know your views on Benny Hill. Go ahead, John. No, no.
甚至是最粗俗、最下流的那些小品秀或喜剧节目，它们依然有一种……你知道我的意思吗？依然有一种圆滑和微妙感。他要切入正题了，他总是要切入正题。他想知道你对本尼·希尔的看法。说吧，约翰。不，不。
But there is. There is, like, so who growing up made you go like, was there anybody you'd watched on the telly or the movies that you were like, oh, that's really interesting? Well, I think it works the other way, too. I mean, we, I'm obsessed with American comedy, and on Channel 4 here, every morning,
但确实如此。确实有，那么成长过程中是谁让你觉得，有没有谁是你从电视或电影里看到，会让你觉得，哦，这真的很有趣？嗯，我觉得反过来也一样。我的意思是，我们，我对美国喜剧痴迷得不行，这里的第四频道，每天早晨
We have Cheers and Frasier and King of Queens and everybody loves Raymond, all those lovely comedies that I remember. Any others or? No. Will and Grace. Oh, shit. Only the good ones.
我们有《欢乐酒店》、《费城故事》（注：应为《欢乐一家亲》Frasier）、《皇后区之王》和《人人都爱雷蒙德》，所有那些我记忆中的美好喜剧。还有其他的吗，还是？没有。
Only the good ones. But literally, and friends and arrested development. Sure, yeah. And we are all, we can sort of quote most of, you know, all my friends, excuse me, adore American comedy. And I find American comedy
只有好剧。只有好剧。但真的，还有《老友记》和《发展受阻》。当然，是的。我们所有人，我们几乎能引用大部分，你知道，我的所有朋友，不好意思，都极其喜爱美国喜剧。而且我觉得美国喜剧
very sophisticated. It's so funny. It's so funny. We all sort of look longingly. I've always my favorite film of all time is Whitnell and I, and I've said it a million times. Oh my God, yes, that's fantastic.
非常精妙。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。我们所有人都会充满向往地看着它。我一直以来最喜欢的电影是《我与长指甲》，我已经说过无数次了。哦天哪，是的，那太棒了。
To me, it is the gold standard because it's not just a comedy, it's quite dramatic. Everything about it is so perfect, and I just find it so hard to believe that somebody can make something like that here. Hard to believe that I have still not seen it. I'm putting it right in right now.
对我来说，这是黄金标准，因为它不仅仅是一部喜剧，它还相当具有戏剧性。它的方方面面都太完美了，我简直难以置信有人能在这里拍出这样的作品。难以置信我竟然还没看过。我现在就把名字记下来。
Oh, it's such a treat. I'm so jealous that you haven't seen it. I know. What's the title again? With nail and I. With nail and I. It's the most perfect film. Richard E Grant.
哦，那真是一种享受。你没看过，我太嫉妒了。我知道。片名叫什么来着？《我与长指甲》。《我与长指甲》。这是最完美的电影。理查德·E·格兰特主演。
Bruce Robinson wrote and directed. Amazing. Yeah, yeah. Amazing. Like with a nail? Oh, God, this is so embarrassing. It's one word. It's the guy's name.
布鲁斯·罗宾逊编剧并导演。太惊艳了。对，对。太惊艳了。就像带着指甲？噢，天哪，这太尴尬了。是一个词。那是那个家伙的名字。
Last name. Okay, but that's why I ask. It's his name. It's a fair question, Sean. I've got you. I've got you. I don't know. I don't know.
姓氏。好吧，但这就是我问的原因。那是他的名字。这是个合理的问题，肖恩。我明白了。我明白了。我不知道。我不知道。
There's something, but there is like, British humor tends to be to sort of lean back just a little bit and lets you kind of discover it, whereas I think we in America, along with everything, we kind of want to show it to you a little bit quicker than you than you might see it. You know, we're a little bit more earnest, a little louder, a little more obvious, I find is the difference.
有些东西，但确实如此，英国幽默往往会稍微往后收一点，让你去发掘它，而我认为我们美国人，和所有事情一样，我们有点想更快地把它展现给你，比你原本发现的速度要快一点。你知道，我们更认真一点，声音更大一点，更直白一点，我发现这就是区别。
And I kind of like having to lean in to find it a little bit more. I love that the dryness and the no winking of British humor so much. I think that's lovely of you, but I do sort of feel that way about watching all of you perform, you know? Yeah, there's, yeah. I wonder, you know, I listed off your credits, and I'm such a fan of so many of these things.
我挺喜欢那种需要你多琢磨一下、去细细品味的风格。我太喜欢英国幽默那种冷面滑稽、从不抛媚眼的风格了。你这么说真是太客气了，不过我看你们所有人的表演时，确实也有这种感觉，你知道吗？是的，有，是的。我在想，你知道的，我列举了你的演艺经历，我是其中很多作品的超级粉丝。
First of all, you know, broad church. Again, that's what an example of a show that is like the gold standard to me. I mean, if every show could, I, for every once in a while, I look, you know, I go into one of my streaming services that I subscribe to and go, like, is there, is there a way, yeah, Britbox, is there a way that there's a new series of broad church?
首先，你知道，《小镇疑云》。再次证明，那是一部对我来说堪称黄金标准的作品。我的意思是，如果每一部剧都能，我，每隔一段时间，我就会看，你知道，我会登录我订阅的某个流媒体服务，然后想，有没有，有没有可能，对，Britbox，有没有可能《小镇疑云》出新剧集了？
And I've just missed it and now it's going to be on. And no, there's not because I love, but you've done so many things. And I think once in an interview you said you don't really, that you're, do you say that you're bad at choosing jobs, you just kind of do the next job that comes along that can't possibly be true. Well, I feel guilty saying no. Yeah. And I think in the early years, you know, not working very often was actually brilliant
而我刚好错过了，现在它就要播出了。然而并没有，因为我太喜欢了。但你演过太多作品了。我想你曾在一次采访中说过，你其实并不觉得自己擅长挑剧本，你只是顺着接下刚好送上门来的下一部戏，这绝对不可能是真的。嗯，我对拒绝别人感到很内疚。对。而且我觉得在早年间，不经常有工作其实是一件非常棒的事
because it's made me very grateful for work. Yeah. Same, same, same. Yeah. And I think it's better that way around than doing really well straight away, I think. But you've had to sharpen your scissors a bit, right? Because I imagine you get a ton of offers and say, submissions and scripts to read and incoming calls because of all the obvious reasons.
因为这让我对工作非常感激。对，一样，一样，一样。是的。而且我觉得比起一开始就顺风顺水，还是这样更好一些。但你也得把剪刀磨得更锋利一点，对吧？因为我能想象，出于所有显而易见的原因，你肯定会收到成吨的邀约、剧本投稿和试镜邀请。
So you can't possibly say yes to everything. And so your picker does need to become somewhat refined. Yeah. Is there something that you really look for that starts to have you lean one particular way? Is it character? Is it script? Is it director? Co-star?
所以你不可能对所有事情都说“好”。因此，你的精挑细选确实需要变得更加敏锐一些。是的。有没有什么东西是你真正会去寻找、并开始让你倾向于某特定方向的？是角色？是剧本？是导演？联合主演？
Location. I don't know. I'm getting slightly better at saying no. because I want to be at home a lot. Yeah. Up until COVID, I had never been away from Ed for longer than two weeks, which in our world is quite unusual. Yeah.
地点。我不知道。我在拒绝别人这方面稍微擅长一点了，因为我想多花时间在家。对。在新冠疫情之前，我离开埃德的时间从来没有超过两周，这在我们的圈子里算是相当罕见的。对。
I didn't really take jobs away from home, and I made sure I got back. Yeah. Because I get quite homesick. And you've got a family. You've also managed to somehow have three kids in there as well. Yeah. And they're really nice. Yeah, I bet. I bet. That's the best. Right. It is. I was talking with a friend about this last night. You know, you could be a great parent, but it's still, you're just still crossing your fingers that you get good ones because it's not really in your control. You can move your kid just a little bit. We've talked about it in the show before in this nature versus nurture. What's your experience been like with that? You've got a great sample. There were three how you never get two of the same. Now you've got three there.
我基本上不接离家远的工作，而且我一定会赶回家。对。因为我会非常想家。而且你还有个家庭。你还在其中奇迹般地生了三个孩子。是的。而且他们真的很好。是的，我敢打赌。我敢打赌。那是最好的。对。确实是。我昨晚还跟一个朋友聊起这个。你知道，你可能是一个伟大的父母，但你依然只能祈祷自己能生出懂事的孩子，因为这根本不在你的控制范围内。你只能稍微引导你的孩子一点点。我们以前在节目里讨论过这个先天与后天的话题。你对此有什么样的体验？你有一个绝佳的样本。有三个，你永远不会得到两个一模一样的。现在你有了三个
are they wildly different? They must be. Well, two are boys, one's a girl. Got, that's a good start. So it's a bit of difference there. But also not really, you know. No? No, and I feel when people talk about difference between genders,
他们性格大不相同吗？肯定是的。嗯，两个男孩，一个女孩。好吧，这算是一个好的开始。所以这里面确实有些不同。但其实也没有，你知道吗？没有吗？没有，而且我觉得当人们谈论性别之间的差异时
I sort of, I don't really see it between them. They all arrived nice. They were so nice when they turned up. Nice. Yeah. And they're all equally amazing. emotional and funny. How old are they?
我其实，我在他们身上并没有感觉到什么区别。他们生下来的时候都很讨人喜欢。他们来到这个世界时太美好了。很好。是的。而且他们同样都非常感性和幽默。他们多大了？
So nearly 20, nearly 18, and nearly 10. So there was a bit of a gap. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. We were home and dry and went back in, had another. Yeah, yeah. Good, good for you, yeah. So is that, sorry, Willie, is the eldest out of the house yet? Is the second eldest about to go out?
一个快20岁，一个快18岁，还有一个快10岁。所以年龄跨度有点大。对，对，对，对。我们本来都把大的拉扯大了，结果又生了一个。对，对，真为你高兴，对。所以那是，抱歉，威利，老大已经搬出去了吗？老二也快要搬出去了吗？
Because I'm dealing with that in our house, and it's just like, it's so like, oh, I hate it. Yeah, so our big one is in his second year of uni. Okay. And second one is, literally did his last A-level today. So he's at the beach now with his friends. How to go? Celebrating. He said it was good.
因为我家里正经历这些，那种感觉就像，哦，我太讨厌了。对，所以我们家老大正读大二。好吧。老二呢，今天刚考完最后一门高级水平考试（A-level）。所以他现在正和朋友在海滩上。考得怎么样？在庆祝。他说感觉不错。
Yeah. Which is words that never came out of my mouth after an exam. And, yeah, the eldest one, when he was about to go to uni, so we knew for a year, obviously, he was going to go to uni. And I pre-greaved, and every time he walked past me, I'd burst into tears. And I just imagine him going, back to being a baby in my arms. And he was so sweet, he would just give me a cuddle.
是的，这话我考完试后从来没说过。而且，是的，老大快要上大学的时候，所以我们提前一年就知道，显而易见，他要去上大学了。我提前就开始悲伤了，他每次从我身边走过，我都会放声大哭。我脑子里总浮现出他回到我怀里当婴儿的样子。他特别贴心，总是会给我一个拥抱。
He just knew I needed it. And then my husband was going, he'll be great. You know, it's exciting. This is what you want for them. And then on the day that we were driving him to uni, our youngest came out of the gate and watched us drive down the road
他只是知道我需要这个。然后我丈夫就会说，他会很好的。你知道的，这很令人兴奋。这就是你希望他们去经历的。然后，在我们开车送他去大学的那天，我们最小的孩子从大门走出来，看着我们的车顺着路开走
and just stood there waving. And Ed burst into tears. And I went, are you fucking kidding? We've got five hours in the car. I don't pull it together. Yeah, yeah. You know, speaking of being a good mom, you and Heart Stopper, like,
就站在那里挥手。埃德当场放声大哭。然后我说，你特么在逗我吧？我们车程还有五个小时呢。赶紧把眼泪收一收。对，对，对。你知道的，说到当个好妈妈，你和《心跳漏一拍》，就像
ay, aye, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like, I wished my mom at the time, she turned around was great when I came out. But that scene that they used in the promo of you listening to your son come out and your response and your reaction. That scene was so powerful. I'm like, it's just incredible.
噢，天哪，对，对，对。就像，我真希望我当年的妈妈，她在我出柜时反应很好。但他们在宣传片里用到的那个场景——你听着儿子出柜，然后做出回应和反应。那个场景太有感染力了。我就觉得，简直不可思议。
And I wish everybody's experience was like. Sean, give me a little. A bit of context. What's the context? So, Heartstopper was about a lot of things, but Olivia played the mom of a kid who came out of the closet and his journey in high school and all of that stuff. Yeah, it's beautiful.
我真希望每个人的经历都能像那样。肖恩，给我一点背景。背景是什么？所以，《心跳漏一拍》讲了很多事情，但奥利维亚饰演的是一个孩子的母亲，那个孩子出柜了，以及他在高中的心路历程等等。是的，太美妙了。
It's coming of age. Yeah. And I think just so beautifully written, it's like the blueprint for, you know, hopefully parents will reply in that way. And a huge hit, massive hits. Yeah, huge hit. People have really loved it.
这是关于成长的。是的。而且我觉得写得太美了，就像是一份蓝本，你知道的，希望父母们能那样去回应。而且大受欢迎，超级受欢迎。是的，超级受欢迎。大家真的很喜欢它。
That's been a lovely response, actually. whenever anyone, often men over the age of 40 get really teared up and go, thank you so much for that. I wish it was that. Really nice. That nice when we were all coming out in the 80s, but anyway. How are you able to keep your two-week thing going
这其实是一个非常美好的反响。每当有任何人——通常是40岁以上的男性——感动得热泪盈眶，然后说：“太谢谢你们拍了这个了。我真希望当年……”真的很好。当年我们大家在80年代出柜的时候要是能那样就好了，但不管怎样。你们是怎么做到把那个两周的约定维持下去的
with as much work that you do away from England? You haven't. Is Ed able to come with you? Does he do something that he can do remotely? We do try to do that Yes, so he is a writer And we have a production company
同时你在英国之外还有那么多工作？你没做到。埃德能跟你一起去吗？他是做什么远程工作的吗？我们确实尽量那样做。是的，所以他是个作家。我们有一家制作公司，
And he sort of runs that I am useless in that And you guys produced You produced the roses Well, you and Ed did Okay, okay, okay Ed and Sunny March That's Benedict's company
他基本上负责运营那个。我对那个一窍不通。你们制作了……你们制作了《玫瑰战争》？好吧，你和埃德制作的。好吧，好吧，好吧。埃德和“阳光三月”（Sunny March）。那是本尼迪克特的连带公司。
Yeah And Fox Searchlight And yeah But not me I'm called an EP on it But I did absolutely fuck all But you get a fee What about
是的。还有福斯探照灯。没错。但是没有我。我在上面挂名执行制片人（EP），但我实际上他妈的什么也没干。但你能拿到片酬。那关于
Where did you shoot that in England? Or are out here in England? No, in England. We were, our characters live in America, but we did, forgive me, UK, for getting Devin and Dorset in a muddle. I mean, that's sacrilege. But we filmed in one of those.
你们是在英国哪里拍的？还是就在英国的户外？不，在英国。我们……我们的角色住在美国，但是我们在……原谅我，英国，把德文郡和多塞特郡搞混了。我的意思是，这简直是大逆不道。但我们是在其中一个地方拍的。
And it was very beautiful. You've done it. I'm going to have to come over and live in America with you now. I miss that. What did you say? I just got two counties in a muddle, and they'll get really upset by that. Oh, oh, oh, got you.
而且非常美丽。你已经拍过了。我现在得搬去美国和你一起住了。我错过了那个。你刚才说什么？我只是把两个英国郡给搞混了，他们会为此非常生气的。哦，哦，哦，明白了。
Oh, wait. So then you both play, you're both. British actors, you played Americans. No, we played English, because they thought, I think, Tony liked the idea of our Englishness in America. Oh, that's great idea. Got you, got you, okay. And the way we properly slag each other off
哦，等等。所以你们俩演的，你们俩都是英国演员，却演了美国人。不，我们演的是英国人，因为我想，托尼很喜欢我们在美国的那种英国特色。哦，那是个好主意。明白了，明白了，好吧。还有我们互相狠狠吐槽的方式，
and the American, incredible American cast, by the way, Kate McKinnon, Andy Sandberg, Zoe Chow. That's great. Yeah. Yeah, amazing. Sunita Mani, just brilliant. Who directed the film? Jay Roach. Oh, Jane Roach.
顺便说一句，还有难以置信的美国演员阵容，凯特·麦金农、安迪·萨姆伯格、佐伊·晁。太棒了。是的。是的，太惊人了。苏妮塔·玛尼，简直绝了。谁导的这部电影？杰·罗奇。哦，简·罗奇。
Yeah. He's a nice man. I love him. Yeah. Lovely. Oh my God. Poor thing. He was like herding cats.
是的。他是个好人。我爱他。是的。太可爱了。天哪。真可怜。他就像是在赶猫。
This is kind of like an all-star movie. This is an all-star movie. All-Star director. All-Star Cass. Yes, he is. August 29th. Oh, nice. I'm just giving you.
这有点像全明星电影。这是一部全明星电影。全明星导演。全明星阵容。是的，他是。8月29号。哦，不错。我只是提醒你一下。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. We all realize it's a business at the end of the day. Listen, you may have got to. Come to the premiere. Come to New York. We're definitely going to come to the show. Will you? Yeah.
对，对，对。我们都意识到归根结底这桩生意。听着，你可能得去。来首映礼。来纽约。我们肯定会去看节目的。会吗？对。
I mean, we'll say we will come. How do you like that. How do you like that. part of it, doing the chat and giggle tour, doing the talk shows and things like and stuff like this. Like, does it come naturally? It's never really to me. Do you like it? Do you enjoy
我的意思是，我们会说我们会去的。你觉得……你觉得这部分怎么样？做这种聊天和搞笑巡回演出，上脱口秀节目以及诸如此类的事情？这很自然吗？对我来说从来都不是。你喜欢吗？你享受
it? No. I has no point lying. I don't. Yeah, right? Did Michelle Pfeiffer, name, say, she does the film for free, it's the press they pay her for? Is that why I kind of feel the same? Yeah, I know. I love Michelle Pfeiffer. Oh, my God. I was going to say
它吗？不。说谎毫无意义。我不喜欢。对吧？米歇尔·普菲花（名字）是不是说过，她拍电影是免费的，片酬是付给她的新闻宣传工作的？这就是为什么我觉得我也有同感吗？是的，我知道。我爱米歇尔·普菲佛。天哪。我本来想说
you mixed up to English counties for which you may never be forgiven. However, you've got so much credit, you've built up so much credit because you played arguably the most iconic English person of all time when you played the queen. In the crown.
你把两个英国的郡给弄混了，为此你可能永远都不会被原谅。不过，你已经积累了极高的声誉，你积累了大量的声誉，因为你饰演了可以说是史上最具标志性的英国人——当你饰演女王的时候。在《王冠》里。
And I gotta ask. I know, I just want to know. The weight. First of all, you were so... Sean, no, sorry, it's not the show. It's not the queen that you're thinking of. No, it's the sequel to Heartstopper, yeah. No, it's not that queen.
我得问问。我知道，我只是想知道。那个分量。首先，你是如此……肖恩，不，抱歉，这不是那个节目。你脑子里想的可不是女王。不，那是《心跳漏一拍》的续集，对。不，不是那个女王。
Got it. Got it, got it. It's not, oh my God, you're here. it's it's it's it's it's what are you wearing how very dare you um no it's it's it's uh you must have been when how did well a couple questions how did that come into your world how did you how did that offer come around and when you got it and the weight of playing the queen as an english person what you felt when you got the offer Wait, well, all of that. Well, I've been watching Claire Foy.
明白了。明白了，明白了。不是，哦天哪，你在这儿。是……是……是……你穿的是什么？你怎么敢？呃，不，是……是……呃，当……你是怎么……怎么……呃，几个问题：这个机会是怎么来到你的世界的？那个邀约是怎么来的？当你拿到邀约时，作为一个英国人去扮演女王的分量，当你接到邀约时你的感受是什么？等等，好吧，所有这些。好吧，我一直在看克莱尔·芙伊的表演。
They'd advertised it so much here, no, big posters everywhere. Yeah. And everyone loved it, which made me go, I'm not going to watch it. I don't want to be pushed into... Right, yeah, yeah. I like to discover things, yes. Yeah, but then, of course, I watched it and absolutely loved it. I was obsessed with Claire Foy.
他们在这里宣传得太厉害了，到处都是巨幅海报。对。而且每个人都喜欢，这让我觉得：我才不看呢。我才不想被强迫去……对，没错。我喜欢自己去发现事物，是的。对，但当然，我看了，而且绝对爱上了它。我迷上了克莱尔·芙伊。
Yeah. And then my agent called me once when I was driving and said, um, that they'd like to see you for... She said the crown. No, she said the queen. that's it, and I went, oh, the play. Oh, and she said, no, no, the telly, what's it called? I went, oh, the crown, are you kidding?
是的。然后有一天我开车时经纪人打电话给我，说，呃，他们想见我去试镜……她说是《王冠》。不，她说的是“女王”。就是那个，然后我说，哦，是那部戏剧。哦，她说，不，不，是那个电视，叫什么来着？我说，哦，《王冠》，你在开玩笑吗？
And I went, absolutely yes. She went, oh, you should think about it. No, no, it's a yes, and it's an absolute yes. And I hadn't really thought about the weight of what it would be. So you're like, I'm all in. I was so excited. Also, to be fair, I had a huge tax bill as well that year. Really came at a good time.
然后我说，绝对去。她说，哦，你应该考虑一下。不，不，这是肯定的，这是绝对肯定的。而且我当时并没有真正考虑过这会带来多大的分量。所以你当时就觉得，我全盘接受。我太兴奋了。而且说实话，那年我还有一大笔税单要交。真的是雪中送炭。
After they saw the cut or? I thought you were going to say, to be fair, I just had a huge gin and tonic, which I'm like, you know. I mean, that's often the case. Yeah, of course, of course. But I was driving. So, well, right, so it was a smaller gin and tonic. So when you get this, so your agent calls and you say, and you say yes, straight away.
是在他们看到剪辑版之后还是？我以为你要说，说实话，我刚喝了一大杯金汤力，就像你懂的。我的意思是，情况往往如此。对，当然，当然。但我当时在开车。所以，好吧，对，所以那是一杯小一点的金汤力。所以当你得到这个消息时，你的经纪人打电话来，你立刻就答应了。
Okay, great. Okay, fantastic. Now, there's the lead up, whatever it is, the months leading up to doing it, and you've got to get your head around playing the queen. So you go in and you meet everybody. I did start to regret my decision a bit because. I thought, oh, actually, this is massive. And, yeah, and everyone knows what she looks like.
好吧，太好了。好吧，太棒了。现在，在拍摄前的准备阶段，无论那是多久，也就是拍摄前的几个月，你得做好心理准备去扮演女王。所以你要去和所有人见面。我其实开始有点后悔自己的决定了，因为
Everyone knows what she sounds like. Yeah. Yeah, and I did start to go, oh, fuck, I shouldn't have done this. Also, I can't walk posh. You can't walk posh. No. Is there a walk? Is there a posh walk?
我想，哦，实际上，这太重大了。而且，是的，每个人都知道她长什么样。每个人都知道她的声音听起来是什么样。是的。是的，我开始觉得，哦操，我不该接这个的。还有，我不会像个贵族那样走路。你不会像贵族那样走路。不会。真有那种走姿吗？真有贵族步态吗？
Yeah, I walk like a farmer. And the director did shout out. He's not pleased that I keep reminding him of this, but he did say, more queen, less farmer, as I was walking. Take your flats off and the heels on. No way. Oh, that's funny. Wait a second.
对，我走路像个农夫。导演还真的喊出来了。他不太高兴我总提起这件事，但他在我走路的时候确实喊过：“多一点女王，少一点农夫。”把平底鞋脱了，换上高跟鞋。不会吧。哦，太搞笑了。等一下。
I love that so much. So you get there, and then it's day one. We've asked this before, which is like that moment when you're going to do your first take and you're rolling for the first time. Oh, God, yeah. And you've got to, and like, okay, I'm now about to. I know that first time you open your mouth and you can sense everyone going, oh, no. And everybody's watching, right, the video village, whatever it is.
我太喜欢这个了。所以你到了那儿，然后就是第一天。我们以前问过这个问题，也就是当你准备拍第一个镜头，第一次开机的那一刻。哦，天哪，是的。而且你必须，就像，好吧，我马上要……我知道那是你第一次张嘴，你能感觉到每个人都在想：“哦，不。”每个人都在看着，对吧，监视器前的所有人，无论那叫什么。
Oh, wrong choice. Oh, really. Let's see her version of the queen. You know what I mean? And I can watch back that first scene I did, and I can tell that I wasn't. Talk about it. Talk about it. Talk about it. I think they did try to do things chronologically. So it was the stamp reveal, you know, when they update our stamps as the monarch ages.
哦，选错人了。哦，真的吗。让我们看看她对女王的诠释。你知道我的意思吗？我能回看我拍的第一场戏，我能看出我当时并不……聊聊这个。聊聊这个。聊聊这个。我想他们当时确实试图按时间顺序拍摄。所以那是邮票揭幕的那场戏，你知道的，就是当君主变老时他们更新我们的邮票。
and so they went from Claire Foy's face, beautiful young Clare Foy, to me. And I guess I really felt incredibly nervous. I think I had a skirt below my knees, but my knees were absolutely going up and down. You know, that's wobbly knee thing. Yeah. And I sounded quite, it was really quite tight in the back of the station.
所以他们从克莱尔·芙伊的脸——美丽年轻的克莱尔·芙伊——切换到了我。我想我当时真的感到无比紧张。我想我穿了一条过膝的裙子，但我的膝盖绝对在剧烈颤抖。你知道那种膝盖发软的感觉吗。是的。我的声音听起来相当……喉咙后半部分真的非常紧绷。
I wonder if that worked, though. I wonder if that worked, like maybe, you know. I don't ever look either. I don't want to know in people. People might have been writing and going, what the fuck, why is she doing it? All right, so then two questions. So it does sound like yes is the answer to the first one, which is do you watch, you know, playback on set or once the job is done? Not on set, no.
不过我在想那管不管用。我在想那是不是管用，也许，你知道的。我从来不看回放。我不想知道人们在想什么。人们可能当时在写评论然后说：“他妈的，她为什么这么演？”好吧，那么有两个问题。听起来对第一个问题的回答是“是的”，也就是你会不会在片场看回放，或者等工作完成后再看？在片场不看，不看。
You can't. So once it's... Because I think it takes too much time. I just want to get the day done. Yeah, yeah. Well, but, exactly. But maybe once they moved on, you know, they're setting up the next shot. I've always found that it's helpful for me to look at, like, just the first couple of days to see if I'm...
你不能看。所以一旦……因为我觉得那太耗时间了。我只想把当天的工作拍完。对，对，对。好吧，但是，确实如此。但也许一旦他们换了场景，你知道的，他们在布置下一个镜头时。我一直觉得对我来说有帮助的做法是，去看一下，比如，头几天拍的东西，看看我是不是……
Well, help the off track or not, right, to see how it's kind of coming across. But you don't. So you wait until it's all done. I didn't really want to on that first day. I think I would have unraveled. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. Sort of, like, oh, I just got to keep going.
好吧，看看有没有偏离轨道，对吧，看看呈现出来的效果怎么样。但你不会。所以你要等到全部拍完。我那天真的不想看。我觉得我会崩溃的。对，对，对。好吧。有点像是，哦，我只能硬着头皮继续拍下去。
It's going to get better. I'll relax as we go. Right. And then once it's done. So, J.B., you're watching the first couple days. You're watching Dailies or you're watching playback. Yeah. To see, either, both.
会越拍越好的。随着拍摄进行我会放松下来的。没错。然后一旦拍完了。所以，JB，你会看头几天的素材吗？你看样片（Dailies）还是看回放？对，看两样。
Really? Yeah. Just to see if I'm kind of in the same movie. like dailies, I'll see scenes that I wasn't on the set for to see if I'm in the same tone, the same project as they are. Oh, that's a good idea. But then once it's out, do you not look at reviews? Well, my husband will show me if it's a good one.
真的吗？对。就为了看看我是不是和大家在同一部电影里。就像样片，我会看到那些我没有参与拍摄的场景，看看我的基调是否和他们一致，是否在同一个项目里。哦，那是个好主意。但等它播出了，你不会去看评论吗？好吧，如果有好评，我丈夫会拿给我看。
And if anyone's been mean, I don't want to see it. Gotcha. Because then that's all you think about. You never remember the good bits. You remember the bad bits that people are saying. I know it. I know. I know. I know.
如果有人说刻薄的话，我才不想看。明白了。因为那样的话，那就会占据你的全部思绪。你永远记不住好的部分。你只会记住别人说的那些糟糕的部分。我懂的。我懂。我懂。我懂。
I know. I know. But I always struggle with like, well, but we're making this for the public and it would be helpful to see if what I think is working works for the masses, right? Because you are looking for a consensus. But don't you ask someone else a trusted friend to look for you? Yeah, but also you are making it for public consumption, but I'm not making it for them. I'm making, I always think like I'm making it for me. Yeah, you have to want to watch it, don't you?
我懂。我懂。但我总是纠结于，好吧，但我们这是做给公众看的，如果能看看我认为管用的东西对大众是不是也管用，那会很有帮助，对吧？因为你是在寻找共鸣。但你难道不会让别人——比如你信任的朋友——帮你看吗？对，但同时，你虽然是做给大众消费的，但我不是为了他们才去拍的。我在拍，我总是觉得我是在为自己拍。对，你得自己想看才行，对吧？
It's tricky. Yeah, it is tricky. Yeah. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. So you were talking about this great cast that he worked with on The Roses and Kate McKinnon and Sandy Sibird. Well, Dan, you're very good at bringing it back around.
这挺棘手的。是的，确实挺棘手。对。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。刚才你们在聊他在《玫瑰战争》中合作的那个伟大的演员阵容，还有凯特·麦金农和安迪·萨伯德。好吧，丹，你很擅长把话题绕回来。
I'm not just doing it for, well, you know, I'm one of the worst interviewers on the planet. No, I think you're doing superb, John. Sean was nominated once when we first started. Sean was nominated for Best Interviewer, and Jason and I were snubbed. Is this why you're all in separate rooms? Yes, we can't be together. This is why I went to Seattle.
我可不仅仅是为了……好吧，你知道的，我是地球上最糟糕的采访者之一。不，我觉得你做得棒极了，肖恩。肖恩刚开始的时候还被提名过一次。肖恩被提名最佳采访者，而我和杰森被冷落了。这就是为什么你们俩在不同的房间吗？是的，我们不能待在一起。这就是为什么我去了西雅图。
But I was going to say with those great people, did you, was there a lot of, there must have been a lot of fun, because Kate McKinnon and Andy in particular are so funny and such great improvisers. And Benedict is wonderful, right? I don't know Benedict at all. Oh my God, yeah.
但我是想说，跟那些杰出的人一起合作，你觉得，里面一定有很多乐趣吧，因为凯特·麦金农和安迪尤其搞笑，而且是非常优秀的即兴演员。本尼迪克特也很棒，对吧？我根本不认识本尼迪克特。哦，天哪，是的。
Yeah, just a tiny bit. I just only met him a couple times, but he seems to have an incredibly good sense of humor. Really does. and just so enthusiastic. Yeah. And like a great, big, intelligent human Labrador. I saw him once repacking his suitcase in the lobby of the Greenwich Hotel.
对，就那么一点点。我只见过他几次，但他似乎有着不可思议的幽默感。真的有。而且总是那么热情。是的。就像一个高大、热情、聪明的巨型人类拉布拉多。我有一次看到他在格林威治酒店的大堂里重新打包行李箱。
That's the only time ever. I didn't say hi, because he looked like he was really, he's really trying to jam something, and this is a true story. He's really trying to change. You know, in that little part right there between the restaurant and the thing, yeah. Wasn't he mumbling stuff like, no, the dogs will smell it here. I could have just swallowed it. I should have just swallowed it.
那是唯一的一次。我没有打招呼，因为他看起来真的很……他真的很努力地想把什么东西塞进去，这是个真实的、不虚的故事。他真的在努力改变。你知道，就在餐厅和那个设施之间的小块地方，对吧？他是不是在嘟囔着诸如“不，狗会闻到这里的气味”之类的话？我本来可以直接把它吞下去的。我本来应该直接把它吞下去的。
but it must have been it must have been a lot of laughs on it like a lot of improvising and there were some scenes where we were all together like a dinner table scene and it was so hard to get through the day and I really felt for poor Jay Roach just no yeah and the crew waiting for you guys to finish giggling I know to stop finding ourselves so funny I know the well did the I've worked with some really incredible actors that are great at and coming up with alternate jokes and stuff. Oh, thanks, man. It makes me go back to my dressing room in between setups
但这其中一定，拍摄时一定有很多笑声吧，比如有很多即兴发挥，而且有些场景是我们所有人都在一起的，比如晚宴的场景，要熬过那一整天真是太难了，我真的很同情可怜的杰·罗奇，没有，是的，还有剧组人员等着你们这群人笑够。我知道，等着我们停止觉得彼此好笑。我知道，好吧，我跟一些非常优秀的演员合作过，他们擅长想出各种替代的笑话之类。哦，谢谢你，伙计。这让我在各个拍摄间隙不得不回到化妆间
and try to catch up and look at my scene and try to come up with other lines so that I was being as sort of creative as they are. Did you find that kind of, not pressure, it's not like a bad thing. I think because I've never written comedy and we were talking about this, Benedict and I, we're very much, Tony McNamara has written it and our job is to do the script and then it was sort of fairly boring of us.
去试图赶上进度、看看我的场景，并试着想出其他的台词，好让自己能像他们一样具有创造力。你觉得那种，也不能说是压力，这不是一件坏事。我觉得因为我从来没写过喜剧，我们之前也在讨论这个，本尼迪克特和我，我们基本上都是——托尼·麦克纳马拉写好了剧本，我们的工作就是照着剧本演，然后我们就会显得相当无趣。
But then you're in the, you know, in a room with Andy Sandberg and Kate McKinnon, for example, and you go, oh, fuck, I mean, I can't do that. I don't think I can do that. Which is also fine. Yeah. And I think, know your strengths, no limits. Exactly, exactly.
但当你身处一个房间里，里面有安迪·萨伯德和凯特·麦金农，举个例子，你就会想：“哦，操，我的意思是，我做不到那个。”我觉得我做不到那样。这也是可以的。对。而且我觉得，了解自己的长处，没有极限。没错，没错。
And I'm so thrilled to have seen them do what they do. You know, S&L alumni. Yeah. It was so fast. Did I say, it's right around? Yeah, that's right. SNL. Yeah, yeah.
我太激动能看到他们展现他们的绝活了。你知道的，周六夜现场（SNL）的校友。对。节奏太快了。我刚才说对了吗？对，没错。SNL。对，对，对。
Can we change lanes for a second? Just talk about the favorite for a minute. It was such a brilliant film. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. How did that come into your world? I think it was because I'd done the lobster with your Goss Lantham. Oh, right. Yes, yeah.
我们能换个话题聊一会儿吗？就聊一分钟《宠儿》。那真是一部精彩绝伦的电影。哦，对，对，对。那个机会是怎么来到你的世界的？我想是因为我之前和你的欧格斯·兰斯莫斯合作过《龙虾》。哦，对的。没错，是的。
Yes, right. And so, what a filmmaker he is. My goodness. Oh, my God, he's amazing. Do it. If he asks you, say yes. Oh, please. I'd pull cable on his set.
是的，没错。所以，他真是一位伟大的电影人。天哪。哦，天哪，他太棒了。去吧。如果他邀请你，一定要答应。哦，拜托。我甚至愿意去他的剧组拉电缆。
Oh, Jason emails him every day. Every day, Jason, emails him. Yeah, I think, I might not have the right address. I'm still alive. No, so, right, so you did the lobster, so then the favorite comes along. God, that film is remarkable. Oh, my God, and I read the script, and I love, you know, when you get proper, sometimes you go, I think I like it. But this one, you go, oh, my God, I could potentially try and run someone over if they were up for
哦，杰森每天都给他发电子邮件。每天都发，杰森，给他发电子邮件。对，我想，我可能地址不对。我还活着呢。不，所以，好吧，你演了《龙虾》，然后《宠儿》就来了。天哪，那部电影太卓越了。哦，天哪，当我读到剧本时，我喜欢——你知道当你拿到真正好的剧本时，有时你会说：“我觉得我挺喜欢它的。”但这一部，你会想：“哦，天哪，如果有人也在竞争同一个角色，我甚至可能会考虑去开车把他们撞死，”你知道的，我太想要这个角色了。
the same job, you know, I want it so much. Right, because it's so clear on the page what a colorful character that is. You must have, like, I would imagine your only challenge was like, what version of color should I do on this character? Because it was just so spicy, right? Yeah, or was it clear to you right from the beginning? Yeah, sort of, yeah. It was so, you know, clear on the page, I thought.
没错，因为剧本把那个丰富多彩的角色写得太清晰了。你一定——我能想象你唯一的挑战就像是：“我应该在这个角色身上展现出哪种色彩？”因为实在是太带劲了，对吧？是的，还是说从一开始对你来说就很清晰？对，差不多，是的。我当时觉得，剧本写得太清晰了。
also some actor friends of mine they read a script and they read it as one thing and then they read it again in another way and they read it again and they see all this and I've never had that and I sort of you know when they talk about their way of doing things
还有我的一些演员朋友，他们读剧本时，读完有一种理解，然后换个角度再读一遍，接着又读一遍，他们能看出所有这些层次，而我从来没有过这种体验，当他们谈论他们做事的方式时，
I panic I think oh God I'm a very simple person I just can't really Yeah I know what you mean And so that reading the favourite I just went oh god I can picture exactly I really want to do it and then I was doing
我会感到恐慌。我会想：“哦，天哪，我是一个非常简单的人，我真的做不到那种……”是的，我懂你的意思。所以在读《宠儿》时，我只是觉得：“哦，天哪，我可以完全想象出来，我真的非常想演。”然后我当时正在拍
Broadchurch I think the third season and I couldn't fit it in and I sort of lump in your throat when you go I'm not failable and he said okay well we'll wait
《小镇疑云》第三季吧，我档期排不开，当你说“我接不了”时，心里会咯噔一下。他说：“好吧，那我们等。”
it was amazing so he waited for me which was what a voter confidence oh God I love him forever for that did you when was the first time you gave him like a little taste of the character Was that scary?
太惊人了。所以他真的等了我，这是多么巨大的信任投票啊。天哪，我永远爱他。你是什么时候第一次向他展现那个角色的一点苗头呢？那会让人害怕吗？
Like, were you sitting around a table? Were you guys progressing at all? He's from theater background, and he does, we did, I think, three weeks of rehearsal. Oh, great. What a luxury. I know. Amazing. It makes for a better product.
比如，你们当时是围坐在一张桌子旁吗？你们当时有在进行任何排练吗？他是戏剧背景出身，我们进行了，我想大概三周的排练。哦，太棒了。这是多么奢侈的待遇啊。我知道。太惊人了。这能带来更好的成片。
Yeah. Also, he does it with sort of theater games. So you might do, he loves to do the whole script from start to finish, but without maybe saying it, you might go, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. In the sort of gist of what you're saying, and you all just go, blah, blah, blah, blah. to each other and get through the whole story. Or you do it all holding hands and you're tying yourselves in a massive knots. You end up with your face near someone's bum and someone's foot in your armpit.
是的。而且他是通过类似于戏剧游戏的方式来排练的。所以你可能会做，他喜欢把整个剧本从头到尾排一遍，但可能不用说出台词，你可能会说：“吧啦吧啦吧啦，吧啦吧啦。”就用你所说台词的大致意思，然后你们所有人就只是对着彼此说：“吧啦吧啦吧啦，”把整个故事过一遍。或者你们手拉着手把大家自己缠成一个巨大的死结。最后你的脸会贴在别人的屁股附近，而别人的脚在你的胳肢窝里。
And so you end up with no inhibitions, pissing yourselves laughing together. So you start your first day on set, you know the film inside out, you know each other, you're totally at ease with each other. I've never done anything like it. It was amazing. It was lovely. It's the best. It's like astonishing that not every director does that.
结果就是你们放下了所有的拘束，一起笑得前俯后仰。所以当你第一天到片场时，你对这部电影了如指掌，你了解彼此，你们对彼此感到完全放松。我从来没做过这样的事。这太惊人了。太美妙了。这是最棒的。每个导演不都这么做，这简直让人匪夷所思。
It's like, don't you want the whole cast to feel like they know each other and, like, there's history there? Otherwise, it's like, hi, nice to meet you, ready to go? Well, I don't know. We haven't had even a dinner together. Yeah, yeah. It's like, I don't understand why it's not always like that, yeah. Oh, I'd love to know more about that.
就像，难道你不想让整个剧组都觉得彼此相熟、并且觉得其中有着共同的历史吗？否则的话，就像是：“嗨，很高兴认识你，准备好开拍了吗？”嗯，我不知道。我们甚至都没一起吃过晚餐。对，对。就像，我不明白为什么不总是这样，对啊。哦，我很想多了解一下那个。
Yeah, that whole rehearsal process. That's amazing. It was really nice. Jason's going to come in London. Go ahead. Thank you. Oh, yeah. We'll all come.
是的，整个排练过程。太惊人了。真的很不错。杰森要去伦敦了。说吧。谢谢。哦，对。我们都会去的。
We'll all come to your rehearsals. Yeah, yeah. That's a good idea. That's a good idea. Yeah, yeah. Let's do that. And do the games and do the stuff so that Jason's face ends up near Sean's bum.
我们都会去参加你们的排练。对，对。这主意不错。这主意不错。对，对。就这么办。玩那些游戏，做那些事，好让杰森的脸最后贴在肖恩的屁股附近。
There we go. For a second time. Wait, Olivia, what were you going to say? I cut you off, I'm sorry. I have no idea, sorry. Okay. My attention to Spanish. No, sorry.
我们就这么定了。等一下，奥利维亚，你刚才想说什么？我打断你了，对不起。我不知道，对不起。好吧。我注意力到西班牙去了。不，不好意思。
So then you went, you know, again, at risk of embarrassing you would further, but you win the Academy Award for the favorite. And... Great speech, by the way. Thank you. I did. I loved the speech.
然后你去了，你知道的，冒着进一步让你尴尬的风险，但你凭《宠儿》赢得了奥斯卡金像奖。而且……很棒的演讲，顺便说一句。谢谢。我确实赢了。我很喜欢那个演讲。
It was so memorable. Thank you very much And then the next So then the next day So you win the Academy Award You're great, Sean's right, great speech And then you win the, and then it's the next morning and you wake up
太难忘。非常感谢。然后下一天……所以接下来的一天……所以你赢得了奥斯卡奖。你太棒了，肖恩说得对，很棒的演讲。然后你赢了，接着就是第二天早晨你醒来，
And then it's like But just get a cup of coffee like every other day Like how, you know Or a couple of ibuprofen And a few coffees and yeah, yeah, of course Yeah, yeah, of late that Yeah Yeah, yeah, kind of bonkers
然后就像……不过就像其他日子一样去喝杯咖啡。怎么说呢，你知道的？或者吃几片布洛芬，
Yeah, and then you've got to fly home with it, right? Yeah, yeah, and and I put it in my hand luggage because I didn't want it to go into the hold of legs. And then as stewardess is asking, can we see it, have you got it? I mean, yeah, I've got it in my bag. How about that going through the, you know,
再喝几杯咖啡，然后，对，对，当然。对，对，最近的那种。对，对，简直太疯狂了。
the actual thing? The Reaper. Yeah. Did they see it? Yeah, I suppose so. They must have done. Just going by the screen. There's an Oscar going through the screen.
然后你得带着它坐飞机回家，对吧？对，对，而且我把它放在我的随身行李里，因为我不想把它托运到货舱里。然后空姐问：“能看看吗？你带着它吗？”我的意思是，是的，我把它放在包里了。带着它过那个，你知道的，
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
实际的安检通道，感觉怎么样？安检机。对。他们看到了吗？对，我想是的。他们肯定看到了。就从屏幕上过。一个奥斯卡小金人正通过安检屏幕。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And you don't want to check it in the luggage and put it in the hold because if they lose it, then it's Good Night Oscar, you know? Oh, my goodness, Will. That's Sean's play.
对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。
That's Sean's play. Good night Oscar. Oh, my God. It's a terrible tieback. So you take it out and are you showing it around the cabin there with the stewardesses and whatnot, or is it just kind of unzip and just take a look in the bag? Just a little look in the bag.
对。而且你不想把它托运在行李里放进货舱，因为如果他们把它弄丢了，那就成了“晚安，奥斯卡”了，你知道吗？哦，天哪，威尔。那是肖恩的戏剧。
Because I find I don't have anything out on show at home. I find it a little. Yeah. But showy off. God, you're so English. You're so English. It's delightful. It's absolutely delightful.
那是肖恩的戏剧。《晚安，奥斯卡》。哦，天哪。这真是个糟糕的梗。所以你把它拿出来，你在机舱里向空姐和随行人员展示它吗？还是说只是拉开拉链在包里看一眼？只是在包里看了一眼。
Is it hidden in a closet somewhere? Yeah, it was in a cupboard in our sitting room. Yeah. Just because I, but we've discovered the cupboard's a bit damp. So we live in a very old house. Our house is, the front of it's 1600. Wow. I bet it's beautiful.
因为我发现我在家里没有任何东西摆在外面展示。我觉得那有点……是的。太炫耀了。天哪，你太英国人了。你太英国人了。太可爱了。绝对太可爱了。
But it's so pretty, but it is a bit damp. it is a bit damp. Yeah. And our lovely Darren, who's a carpenter, handyman painter, he opened the cupboard,
它是藏在某个衣柜里吗？对，它在起居室的一个橱柜里。是的。只是因为我……但我们发现那个橱柜有点潮湿。所以我们住在一栋非常古老的房子里。我们的房子，正面是1600年建的。哇。我敢说它一定很漂亮。
went, Oh, are you fucking kidding? You know I'm stamping here. And so he made me take it out, and I've now got it on a bookshelf, but behind a book. So that's... I know it's there,
但它是那么漂亮，不过确实有点潮湿。确实有点潮湿。是的。我们可爱的达伦——他是个木匠、杂工兼油漆工——他打开那个橱柜，
and I can say hello to him. No, that's nice. It's really nice. That's very good. So Darren rescued him. You get another one? make bookends you know then you're gonna have to look at it so so before we let you go i mean you you got a very busy life you're you're working all the time you're just you i mean you could
说：“哦，你他妈在开玩笑吧？你知道我在这儿盖章呢。”所以他让我把它拿出来，我现在把它放在一个书架上，不过在一本书后面。所以……我知道它在那儿，我还可以跟它打个招呼。不，那挺好的。真的挺好。那非常好。所以达伦救了它。你再拿一个？做成书档，你知道的，那样你就不得不看着它了。所以，在我们放你走之前，我的意思是，你过着非常忙碌的生活，你一直在工作，你只是……我的意思是，你可以
and a mom and you're a mom and you're a mom and you have and you're doing all and you're out in the country's out what do you do is there we always ask people is there one sort of guilty pleasure like thing that you do like little like sort of tv that you watch that you enjoy the dumbest thing What's the, do you do anything dumb as a sort of hobby that's kind of secret nobody knows about? I think I tell everybody everything, so nothing's really very secret. Good for you. I really love shit reality telly.
而且是个妈妈，你是个妈妈，你是个妈妈，你拥有这一切，而且你住在乡村……你做什么？我们总是问别人，有没有一种像是内疚的快乐，就是你做的小事，比如你看的一些很蠢的电视节目，你很享受？最蠢的事情是什么？有没有什么作为秘密爱好的蠢事是没人知道的？我觉得我什么都告诉别人了，所以真的没什么秘密。那很好。我真的很喜欢垃圾真人秀。
Yeah, good, there we go. My God, have you seen Too Hot to Handle? No. It's fucking brilliant. What is that? Is that up there with, like, Love Island and Below Deck and stuff like that? Below Deck, I love Below Day. Yeah, I didn't either.
对，太好了，就是这样。天哪，你看过《欲罢不能》（Too Hot to Handle）吗？没有。太他妈精彩了。那是什么？那是和《爱情岛》（Love Island）以及《下甲板》（Below Deck）之类的一类节目吗？《下甲板》，我爱《下甲板》。是的，我也没有。
Love Island I've never seen. But Too Hot to Handle is. Please watch it. So it's all these really over-sexed, incredibly hot, beautiful people who are on this island. They're told they're there for a show, a dating show. And then it's great. And then the presenter comes on and says,
《爱情岛》我从来没看过。但《欲罢不能》真的是……请一定要看。所以就是一群非常饥渴、超级性感、漂亮至极的人在一个岛上。他们被告知他们是来参加一个节目，一个约会节目。然后就很棒。接着主持人出场说，
actually, you're all here for too hot to handle. And you can see them going, oh, God! Because it means that they're not allowed to touch each other. And they start with a money pot of like 100 grand. And they forget that there's a million. cameras in this house. And anyone, so masturbation is like five grand, a snog is two grand. It's hilarious. It's so funny. It's so good. And then the next morning, this sort of, it's like a, what are those, I don't have one, those gadgets in the house that you can talk to.
实际上，你们所有人来这里都是为了《欲罢不能》。然后你能看到他们露出：“哦，天哪！”的表情，因为这意味着他们不被允许互相触碰。他们从一笔10万美元的奖金池开始。而且他们忘了这房子里有一百万个摄像头。任何人……所以自慰要扣5000块，亲吻要扣2000块。太搞笑了。太好笑了。太棒了。然后第二天早上，这种……就像是一个，那些是……我没有那个，屋里那些你可以跟它说话的小玩意儿。
Oh yeah, like an Alexa. So this Alexa type thing goes, let's all meet on the sofa. And they'll go, I haven't, I haven't, if you, who's lost us some money? And then she says, the money pot is now down to 90 grand. Someone was being shamed. And they're all looking at each other. And you've got to figure out who did it. And then they go to like a hand moving under the duvet. Oh, my God.
哦，对，像亚马逊Echo（Alexa）那样。所以这个类似Alexa的东西就会说：“让我们都在沙发上集合吧。”然后他们会说：“我没有，我没有……谁让我们损失了一些钱？”接着她说：“奖金池现在降到了9万块。有人觉得羞耻了。”然后他们都在互相看着。你得找出是谁干的。然后他们就放录像，比如被子底下一只手在动。哦，天哪。
It's so funny. Wait, I've got to see it. 10 grand, but it's only five grand. Yeah, no, Gary jerked off twice. Oh, that sounds so good. Wait, is that on British Shadows? And sometimes I think totally worth it. I'll take it.
太搞笑了。等等，我必须得看。1万块，但其实只有5000块。对，不，加里自慰了两次。哦，听起来太棒了。等等，那是英国的……有时候我觉得完全值得。我认了。
Yeah. this show or is it on like Netflix or something like that? I have a feeling it's... American. I've seen it with Americans and English. I think it... All right. What about the traders? Have you seen the traitors? Do you know that show? Love traitors. Love it. Yeah, I love it too. We play it. We have gone
对。这个节目还是在Netflix之类的平台上？我感觉它是……美国的。我看到过美国人和英国人版本。我想……好吧。那《叛徒》（The Traitors）呢？你看过《叛徒》吗？你知道那个节目吗？超爱《叛徒》。太爱了。是的，我也超爱。我们玩这个。我们每年
holiday every year with four families and we play Mafia. Same. Yeah, during the pandemic... Yes, now listen to this. During the pandemic, we were playing Mafia on Zoom with like 20 people, right? And after like 10 times... I'm like, I feel like this is a TV show but I didn't do anything about it and then cut to
都和四个家庭一起去度假，我们玩“黑手党”（杀人游戏）。一样。对，在大流行期间……是的，听着。在大流行期间，我们在Zoom上和大概20个人一起玩“杀人游戏”，对吧？在大约10次之后……我觉得这就像是一个电视节目，但我当时什么也没做，然后镜头切到
one of the biggest shows in the history of the world, the traitors. I mean, it's exactly the same thing. Where do I find that? Well, Sean. Peacock is at the Alan Cumming, the American version. I haven't seen the American one yet. Oh yeah, and I've seen the UK version as well
世界上规模最大的节目之一——《叛徒》。我的意思是，这完全是同一回事。我在哪能看到那个？嗯，肖恩。孔雀（Peacock）上有阿兰·卡明主持的美国版。我还没看过美国版呢。哦，对，我也看过英国版，
and then what's her name? Claudia Winkleman. She's great. Who's my friend Chris's wife. She does the UK version. Oh my gosh, she's incredible. You know her? I do, yeah. She's my friend Chris T.K.'s.
然后叫什么来着？克劳迪娅·温科尔曼。她很棒。她是我的朋友克里斯的妻子。她主持英国版。哦，天哪，她太不可思议了。你认识她？我认识，对。她是我朋友克里斯·T.K.的……
I would love to meet her. Yeah. But, J.B., remember, we played Mafia every night at New Year's this past years. Yeah, I'm always surprised. With the kids and with every, we had all our kids. We had everywhere. Yeah, the kids all play. Do you find, if you get murdered, you know it's your kids that have done it?
我很想见她。对。但是，JB，记住，我们今年跨年夜每天晚上都在玩“杀人游戏”。对，我总是很惊讶。和孩子们一起，跟每一个人，我们所有的孩子都在。我们到处都是。对，孩子们都玩。你发现了吗，如果你被“杀”了，你知道那是你的孩子们干的吗？
It's every time. It happened a lot. It happened a lot. Kids always murder their parents. I ended up, I tell you what, I ended up. having to run it most of the times. I only got to play, like, twice of, like, the 20 times we did it, which was a bummer.
每次都是。经常发生。经常发生。孩子们总是“杀”他们的父母。我最后，我告诉你，我最后不得不
And if I get, if I pick the killer card and I'm the murderer, I start laughing immediately. Like, I'm the worst. What, you do a killer, you guys do cards that you pick? Or somebody is, yeah, yeah, you pick a sign. We assign, we assign, we, every close their eyes and we go around, and whoever's running it assigns. Okay, good.
大多数时候由我来主持。我们玩了大概20次，我只玩到了两次，这太糟糕了。而且如果我抽到“杀手”牌、我是凶手的话，我会立刻笑出来。比如，我是最差的。什么，你们当凶手时，你们玩的是抽牌吗？或者有人是……对，对，你们抽标志。我们分配，我们分配，我们让每个人闭上眼睛然后我们走一圈，谁在主持就由谁来分配。哦，很好。
Oh, we do cards. Yeah, we do, interesting. Same as Sean. And we have the same guy called Guy, who is the best, guy at running it and he loves it. He likes to run in. He's got a gentle Welsh accent and it really works. He loves it.
哦，我们用牌。对，我们用，有意思。和肖恩一样。我们也有一个叫盖伊（Guy）的家伙，他是主持这个游戏最棒的人，他超爱主持。他喜欢主持。他带着温和的威尔士口音，效果真的很好。他太喜欢了。
That would be so fine. Olivia, if we see each other in London, we should play. Oh my God, we will. I'll get guy along. Yeah. He can run do it while me and Amanda are there, Shawnee. Yeah, yeah, we should. That'd be so fun. Let me know. Well, Olivia Coleman.
那一定太棒了。奥利维亚，如果我们在伦敦碰面，我们应该玩一玩。哦，天哪，我们会的。我把盖伊也叫上。对。等我和阿曼达都在的时候，他可以主持，肖尼。对，对，我们应该玩。那一定太好玩了。告诉我。好吧，奥利维亚·科尔曼。
I'm so thrilled to meet you. I've had such a nice time. What an absolute thrill. What a huge massive fan we all are of yours massive fans well me too i was incredibly nervous for the first half of this my heart was going like mad oh and then ed came in with the with the with the with the with the with the lubrication i bless ed you can tell that i needed a little you were fantastic you were awesome very nice of you to do this nice to meet you thank you for doing this oh thank you for having me have a great i'll see you in london or we'll play math yes in london and a lot of success with the roses
很高兴能见到你。我度过了一段非常美好的时光。绝对是一场巨大的惊喜。我们所有人都是你超级无敌的粉丝，超级粉丝。我也是，我今天前半场紧张得要命，我的心脏怦怦直跳，哦，然后埃德带着润滑剂进来了……上帝保佑埃德，你可以看出我刚才有点……你太棒了，你太厉害了。你来这里真是太好了，很高兴认识你，谢谢你来做客。哦，谢谢你们邀请我。祝一切顺利，伦敦见，或者我们在伦敦玩杀人游戏，祝《玫瑰战争》大获成功，
august 29 once again very happy for you and your success yeah oh thank you so much that i'm I'm a huge fan of all of you, and I'm really gratefully had me on. Thank you. Thank you, honey. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. What a nice. It was like a strawberry Wimbledon breakfast, you know. Sure.
再次恭喜你取得的成功。哦，非常感谢，我是你们所有人的超级粉丝，非常感激你们邀请我来。谢谢。谢谢，亲爱的。再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。多么美好。就像是温布尔登的草莓早餐，你知道的。确实。
What's a strawberry, Wimbledon? I don't know what, the creams, it just feels so refreshing and European, you know, first thing in the morning. Yeah, it was really nice. You know, people who are that joyful work a lot. I like that. You think that? That's the key.
什么是草莓温布尔登？我不知道是什么，奶油，感觉清新又具有欧洲风情，你知道的，一大早。是的，真的很好。你知道，那些充满快乐的人工作都很多。我喜欢这样。你这么觉得？那是关键。
Well, I think it's part of it, don't you think? Sure, exactly. I mean, nobody wants to hire assholes. No, exactly. This is what I keep telling you, Sean. Straighten out. Get in line. I mean, it's, yeah.
嗯，我觉得这是其中的一部分，你不觉得吗？当然，完全如此。我的意思是，没有人想雇佣混蛋。不，完全如此。这就是我一直对你说的，肖恩。端正态度。规矩点。我的意思是，这，是的。
She does work a lot. She's in so many different things and so many different types of roles. I forgot this is how she's in the bear. She also recurring. Yeah. No way. Yeah.
她确实工作很多。她演了那么多不同的作品，扮演了那么多不同类型的角色。我都忘了她还演了《熊家餐馆》。她也是常驻演员。真的吗？
What's she doing in that show? I don't know, man. She's poking the bear. I guess she pokes the bear. Sounds like a dream. What about the, what about where she lives is just in the middle of the countryside
她在里面演什么？不知道，伙计。她去搅局（poking the bear）。我想她就是去搅局的。听起来像个梦想。那关于……那关于她住的地方，就在英国乡村的中央，
in England? I mean, doesn't that sound amazing? And you can just sort of see here, like, just kind of children laughing in the wind just sort of, you know, gentle breeze through the trees and the birds and stuff is light. Some ice clattering against the side of the glass. Large genitonic.
我的意思是，那听起来不是很棒吗？你仿佛能看到，就像……孩子们在风中欢笑，微风轻拂过树林和鸟儿什么的。有些冰块敲击着玻璃杯壁的声音。大杯的金汤力。
Yeah, yeah. With something grilling on the thing outside and friends over, maybe some mafia late in the night. Yeah. Is he trying to get closer to a bomb? you know I don't know
对，对。外面有什么东西在烤架上滋滋作响，朋友们聚在一起，也许深夜还要玩上一局“杀人游戏”。对。他是不是在试图把“田园风光”（bucolic）这个词扯进来？你知道我不知道
when did Rob just send what does that word mean but he's trying to he's pitching a bye here and it's something like brov arm yard is trying to pitch a bye alcoholic yeah it's like bucolic but
罗布刚发的是什么？那个词是什么意思？但他是在这里推销一个词，类似于“郊野风光”（brolm yard），他正试图推销一个跟酒有关的词……对，就像是“田园风光”（bucolic）但……
bicolic what is that even mean bucolic what does that even mean bucolic bucolic is sort of country leafy and tree outdoors it's pretty good one I actually think it's nice but it's view and not buy
“田园风光”（bucolic），那到底是什么意思？“田园风光”，那到底是什么意思？“田园风光”是一种乡村、绿树和户外的感觉。这其实是个不错的词。我其实觉得挺好的，但是是“view”（风景）而不是“buy”（买）。
I'll tell you it would be good if you could somehow work in the word combined into something like that you could really lean on the bye section combined. Right, if you took the two but then you were saying, and you put two saying, yeah, right.
我告诉你，如果你能以某种方式把“combined”（结合）这个词融入到类似的东西中，你就可以真正强调“buy”那个部分。对，如果你把这两个结合起来，然后你在说，对，没错。
So, oh, I know, she's an actress that can do comedy and drama, so I don't know. What if she found the perfect role where you... Oh, what? Oh, do she take the two things and she was able to... Oh!
所以，哦，我知道，她是一个既能演喜剧又能演正剧的演员，所以，我不清楚。如果她找到了那种完美的角色，让你……哦，什么？哦，她把这两者结合起来，然后她能够……哦！
Come by! Wow! You guys! Yes! Come by, Collick. Smartless Smart Smartless
一起来！（Come by!）哇！你们！是的！快来，田园风光（Come bucolic）。聪明绝顶 聪明绝顶 聪明绝顶
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry Rob Armjarf and Bennett Barbego Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特瑞、罗布·阿姆加夫和本尼迪克特·巴贝戈100%有机手工打造。Smartless。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。